we've covered a lot here on this channel
and what you might have noticed about
the nature of our discoveries is that
knowledge is best broken down before
digested which is to say if you are to
learn how to assemble a computer it may
benefit you also to see one taken apart
when you do so you'll notice in front of
you not a computer at all but a
collection of individual parts it's in
understanding these distinctive parts in
isolation that helps us shape our
awareness of their marriage and how they
cooperate with one another to become
their collective self sure this may be
good in practice but then tell me how do
we comprehend a hole that is composed of
parts unwilling to isolate themselves
from the rest because let's face it not
all things let alone scps can be torn
apart for the convenience of our study
no matter the subject we seek to
understand it may choose to resist our
deconstruction by one way or another
landmarks like the temples of malta and
the pyramid of jose are held together by
our respect monuments like the statue of
liberty are held together by copper the
family was held together by charles
manson but it's not always the
preservation of history or elements of
the periodic table or psychopaths that
reject humans wishes to disassemble far
stronger than forces of nuts and bolts
are that of character and loyalty and
scp-2085
is welded together by exactly that
scp-2085 is a militant anarchist
organization consisting of six
cybernetically enhanced individuals a1
through a5 and b operating under the
name kuroy usagi shiden or more commonly
known as the black rabbit company
scp-2085-a subjects are five adult
female augmented humans designated
scp-2085-8-1
through scp-2085-8-5
subjects are genetic chimeras each with
an estimated six to ten different gene
donors they are fluent in japanese
mandarin chinese cantonese korean
russian and english with additional
languages varying by individual subjects
display an array of genetic and
cybernetic enhancements including
genetic splices of felis katus
physiology that is having cat-like ears
tails and hair these tails are
prehensile and capable of holding small
objects so if you're accusing one of
them of stealing your pen don't just go
searching their pockets they also have
grip pads on hands and feet in case they
ever did decide to retire from anarchy
and take up surfing their impressive
features don't stop there if they
haven't already put james bond's gadgets
to shame yet just wait daniel craig is
about to look like dora the explorer
scp-2085-a-1 through a-5 all have ocular
implants with thermal vision heads-up
display and recording functionality also
noted are carbon nanoweave muscle fiber
augmentation reinforced endoskeleton and
brain computer interface with internal
hard drive the list goes on each etc
more elaborate than the next yet what
stands out most about them is not a
weapon but an attitude these six members
although now held in isolation from one
another do not show any signs of
splitting up not even when under the
heavy pressure of the foundation's
interrogation agents spend their hours
looking for cracks to dig their fingers
into trying to get one to betray the
other and reveal sensitive information
but when asked to spill the beans
scp-2085 screws the lid on tighter they
remain as a whole resistant to our
deconstruction the agents get nowhere
with their investigation and with each
minute wasted it's another victory for
scp-2085
the hours go on and they keep stacking
up w's building momentum day after day
growing stronger and stronger as a unit
as the foundation tries to tear the
group apart they respond with even
greater resistance and this style of
resistance is unique to each member
imagine you are confronting scp-2085-8-2
she is talkative and so you think you
might get somewhere you are all ears but
what scp-2085-8-2
sees isn't ears but troths and she is
happy to feed you her slop she talks and
talks and you listen closer and closer
but all you are getting is
misinformation false names inaccurate
stories dates that don't add up you
focus and follow along only to find
yourself having run a marathon all the
way to a dead end now you are faced with
scp-2085-8-5
who takes a different more nonsensical
approach you are happy to no longer have
to sit through inaccuracies to decipher
truths but now there are no truths at
all all that you are given are
absurdities she speaks in a way that
makes you scratch your head one saying
for no apparent reason i take a hammer
and i break my legs i break them for the
better after so many scratches you swear
you've dug an inch into your skin and so
you move on to scp-2085-a-4
hoping for better luck she is
straightforward with you that much you
like but she's hostile and doesn't
cooperate when you ask her her name she
raises her middle finger she tucks it
back in to create a fist and then that
fist punches the divider between you no
amount of reinforced glass could make
you feel safe at that moment cracks
spread it looks like a web spun by a
spider and you feel as small as one
thankfully a protective shutter is
lowered aerosol sedatives are pumped
into the containment unit she continues
to try to escape yelling profanities
even harsh for someone locked behind
bars your ears have taken a beating from
curse words nonsensical rambles and
heaps of misinformation you want to
lower your head into a toilet bowl and
hear nothing but water yes that is where
these women have driven you your head to
the bottom of a toilet bowl you have put
in so many hours and yet you have
learned nothing new and if you can't
learn anything new you might have to
rely more on what you already know but
what do you know well you know this
their track record is quite impressive
verified operations include smuggling
theft assault vandalism kidnapping
extortion property damage possession of
fissile materials corporate sabotage
embezzlement identity theft fraud
copyright infringement piracy possession
transport and sale of anomalous items
and of course tax evasion yet when
grilled under the heat of investigation
they do not reveal any details about the
nature of these operations you just know
that they happened all that is told is
that
scp-2085 navigates in such a way as to
minimize the chance of civilian
casualties and maximize material and
morale damage to their target they are
proud of this it seems as if scp-2085
perceives themselves on the side of good
while their list of operations on paper
look like crimes they stand proudly
behind them pleading guilty with a grin
but behind every smile is more teeth
teeth that go beyond saying cheese teeth
hiding in the dark caves of a sealed
mouth and you are determined to play
dentist and find your way in but
scp-2085 doesn't say
ah for just anyone so how are you to
understand a group that resists our
preferred methods of learning how are
you to properly assess the pieces of a
puzzle when the puzzle is glued tightly
together it starts at the top before you
can decipher the motives of a nation
you'd be smart to study their leader and
if you want to extrapolate the schemes
of a football team you'd interview the
coach and to truly know the moral of a
television show you'd be better off
asking the creator than the actors all
of this is just to say if you are to
ever understand the complexities of
scp-2085
it is necessary you begin with
scp-2085-b
the person pulling the string of the
entire operation for all of these years
now you might be imagining a man of many
muscles someone able to fight a bear
with an arm tied behind his back
someone who kicks through saloon doors
tilts back his liquor and walks out with
a woman in each arm or a cat girl but
you'd be dead wrong scp-2085-b
also known as wizard does not look like
an imposing lead at first glance or even
at the hundredth glance he is generally
in very poor health and his face shows
it he suffers from a variety of
illnesses most notably a vitamin d
deficiency acute radiation syndrome and
has unmanageable scarring from severe
and repeated skin ulceration he doesn't
wear a cape and glamorous spandex often
found hanging in superheroes closets but
instead he wears an advanced crew escape
suit accompanied by a cheap bathrobe and
flimsy red felt wizard's hat he looks
with no elegant way of putting it like a
dork a goofball a doofus
you get the point furthermore he is an
adult male human with certain cybernetic
and genetic enhancements he has an
adaptation of the gastrointestinal tract
to allow for an all-liquid diet within
his suit an esophageal input port and
waste output port are integrated it is
equipped with modifications to regulate
sweat reduce abrasion damage from
extended usage and aid in skin
regeneration his genetic enhancements
include the replacement of 11 previously
missing digits on hands and feet and
also has an internal drug pump typically
used for painkillers because as we are
about to learn scp-2085-b
is most often on the wrong end of pain
notice these modifications are not those
you would find in a science fiction
novel but more likely behind the trench
coat of a suspicious man in a dark alley
and we all know nothing good is ever
concealed behind a trench coat but have
you ever wondered if that truth also
extends to robes because when we pull
open scp-2085s
what we find is truly terrifying
scp-2085-1
scp-2085-1 is a fibrous mass of
self-replicating carbon nanomaterials
within
scp-2085-b's chest cavity with growths
protruding into the liver pancreas
gallbladder spinal cord and left lung
the growth of the scp-2085-1
and its consumption of
scp-2085-b's body tissues has been
impeded through the addition of various
containment implants used to sever
communication between growth sections
and control nodes and counter the
replication process
scp-2085-1's rate of replication without
the influence of these containment
implants is unknown scp-2085-1
periods of activity occur on average
once every three months the process
lasts for up to 15 minutes and causes
scp-2085-b intense pain
imagine a heart attack imagine mike
tyson using your sternum like a punching
bag imagine a cactus strapped to your
front this is the pain and torture
scp-2085 wears daily there is no s logo
printed on his chest like superman no
symmetrically slick symbol like batman
instead just cancerous growth kryptonite
worn like a tie the knot never to be
loosened but to scp-2085-b
this anomaly is not just a number to be
studied but more so a being to be
understood it is more personal than a
medical condition it is something that
he wakes up with each and every day he
calls it red at first the foundation saw
scp-2085's close connection with red to
be childish and silly as if a small boy
who names his freckles out of boredom
and loneliness but as you are about to
see how they met was more memorable than
first finding a freckle in the mirror a
meteor struck down and scp-2085-b
was the only person at the scene red was
inside as wizard approached the meteor
red leapt onto him and buried a home
into his chest cavity far from a freckle
on the skin red is a cancer it grows and
grows leeching to what it can it can't
be removed with surgery it can't be
covered by a band-aid it has no empathy
or mercy it leaches on and eats away at
its host but it's more than pain that it
causes falling off a swing set and
bursting open your leg hurts sure but at
least both you and your injury are on
the same team cuts try to heal when left
alone injuries make effort to find
homeostasis but red is a different breed
it hates us in a way that injuries are
incapable of doing it has a deep disdain
for humanity it tears wizard down
reveling in his degradation its sole
purpose is to eat him whole wizard can
only take this personally as he doesn't
just feel the universally understood
sensation of pain but also the unique
passion of its purpose
scp-2085-b's adventures with red seem to
be where our story begins and what
ultimately keeps it moving in fact it
was while scp-2085-b
was running around trying to fix his
chest with implants when he eventually
met who we refer to as scp-2085-8-1
through a-5 he was at the clinic to get
some new parts and when he was going
through the installation process there
was an explosion one of the five girls
barged out of a building guns blazing he
started running alongside them with his
chest half open the woman embraced him
immediately and reciprocated knowing
nothing of the situation he
instinctively knew to take their side
there were bullets coming from both
directions but he intuitively understood
which side was good and which side was
bad a distinction as cp 2085 believes
the world needs help clarifying but it
is hard to see a reason for a war when
our eyes are focused on the casualties
beliefs are less clear when tucked
behind bullets the sounds of gunfire
muffle their message morality while a
complex subject
scp-2085 believes is simplified by the
masses events are deemed good or bad
based on the term used for them in a
court of law when we see the words
smuggling theft assault vandalism
corporate sabotage embezzlement identity
theft fraud copyright infringement
piracy and of course tax evasion it is
our impulse to label those as morally
bad but scp-2085 desperately wants you
to look beyond the language they want
the words to dissipate off the paper
letter by letter until all you have is a
blank page now look at the pencil and
the hand that holds it watch how it
moves that is what matters whether it
draws weapons or mermaids is irrelevant
both can be used for good both can be
used for evil intent is everything
and scp-2085
intends on making the world a better
place or so they like to claim but maybe
there is more to it after
scp-2085-b and the five women escaped
the gunfire they went on to steal a boat
and hightail it out of japan they spent
their nights out there on the ocean
stargazing and stuffing themselves with
instant ramen and cheap beer and
surprisingly between all the crazy
adventures as cp 2085-b had been on this
is what wizards spoke about most the
time spent on the boat out at sea for
the first time in ages he was finally
somewhere where he was happy it was this
moment that actually meant the most to
him it wasn't the children they
apparently save from imperialism it
wasn't the wealth they apparently
redistributed to the poor it wasn't any
good deed at all it was the selfish
almost shallow sensation of being happy
on a boat this singular moment meant so
much to scp-2085-b
he reflected on it as if it were a
wedding day or a memorable vacation
which makes you wonder scp-2085
has been investigated and interrogated
and all that they preach is that they
are doing the world a favor with their
antics their tales are captivating sure
but is it actually storytelling or is it
just virtue signaling there is an
emotional depth to scp-2085 unique to
any other militant anarchist group while
they are genetically designed to most
efficiently complete missions they are
not all robots fixed on the high of task
completion each and every one of them
wants more they want a group they want a
group not just to have the numbers to
overthrow a government but to have the
numbers to fill a room or boat with
companionship when they refuse to
cooperate with you and leak information
about their operation maybe what you are
witnessing isn't the strength of their
loyalty but also the weakness of their
co-dependence and so you decide this is
the new angle you're going to take with
your interrogation you enter the room
with a new focus you feel like an
earthquake eager to make cracks in their
core you isolate scp-2085-8-4
you are met expectantly with hostility
you fight back with psychology you cross
your legs and put on your glasses as if
to say let's talk about that anger where
does it stem from she strengthens her
emotional guard but you keep prying you
say that it sounds like she is lonely
you say it sounds like her loyalty
doesn't come from good character but
rather insecurity and self-doubt you
asked her if completing missions with
her crew was actually a way to improve
the world or was it just an elaborate
way to build a close friend group bound
together by common goals did new
missions sprout from necessity or were
they fabricated by fears of being alone
with nothing to do were end of operation
high fives to celebrate good overcoming
evil or were they just excuses to feel
the touch of another human skin to skin
you stop there and let silence do the
rest scp
2085-8-4 sits with her thoughts she is
ready to break and finally she does she
says she's willing to provide video logs
of the group's former operations she's
ready to cooperate she's ready to
abandon loyalty to groupthink and focus
instead on self-improvement in exchange
she kindly asks that she be reciprocated
and that the sanction placed on her be
lifted you come to an agreement and with
that you feel like your work is done but
is it you're feeling cocky and
accomplished you forward the video logs
to an isolated network for d-class
personnel to review and you sit back and
enjoy a celebratory drink you have
infiltrated and broken the mind of a
genetically modified radical designed
for anarchy you give yourself a pat on
the back and you're feeling so great
that the pat might even turn into a
massage but before you can indulge in
that deep tissue level of
self-admiration the phone rings can it
be a call from the president telling you
that you're the greatest investigator of
all time can it be that they need you to
pose in front of a world-renowned artist
so they can erect a statue of you in the
center of town square but the panic on
the other side of the phone halts your
daydream your stomach drops as if a
sudden plummet from a perfectly vertical
roller coaster you have fallen into a
trap the video log at the center of your
negotiation was not all it was promised
to be the file titled backup.avi
consisted of a two-hour long video of a
feces-filled toilet presumably recorded
from
scp-2085-a's point of view accompanied
by an audio loop of the folk song koro
baniki as performed by the red army
choir its absurdity feels like an art
project like a short film you are
assigned to watch in a community college
class but instead of putting you to
sleep it does a whole lot more the
contained audiovisual cognitohazard
induced anaphylaxis and exudative
diarrhea in the observing d-class
subject the d-class subject died four
minutes after initial access of the file
from blood loss and oxygen deprivation
scp-2085-4 sits in containment laughing
while you sit there on your couch
dethroned back where you started having
thought you tore scp-2085 apart with
your mind only to learn that your
efforts only reinforced it with more
glue now go check out scp-240
a harmless kitten and
scp-577 bullet cat for more scps that'll
melt or claw out a cat lover's heart